[Music]
okay Cynthia nagels so it's probably
spent more packable good father already
done cleaning my money you can tell [ __ ]
fixing to go do my workout we gone for a
couple hours we have a minute the others
I kind of have to change them what did
you do at school why does all have to be
something I get is a good when you saw
on you talking about something you said
oh you know I love you love Jennifer
coffee why now is she calling you you
know she's having a wedding and I will
be a father all right yes I know yes
when you go pick up some flowers with
dresses for the wedding me and her just
be in her I don't know why I know
Jennifer would call an 11-year old and
not me I mean whatever woman does that
I'm an issue that dear to me but I don't
want to go by myself I wouldn't let you
go without me there sure I know that
much I'll go anywhere people y'all don't
know so I was going to ask if you want a
poem for not sugar bear not Jennifer for
me for life school that'll happen my
Nestle messed up especially about an
event like this
you
[Music]